I teach at a university and the students
I teach you know we're born around the
time of the beginning of the book or you
know just a tad earlier and you know
they are of a generation that has been
convinced by the George W Bush
administration that everything changed
on 911 and the world was completely we
faced a completely new world well what
happened on 911 is we woke up as a
population to things that were already
in train out there and what what people
need to understand who don't remember
the 90s is that when we talk about
problems like terrorism Iraq Iran North
Korea in a rise of China sort of all
these issues that we face climate change
the global economy all these things were
going on already and and we were trying
to figure out how best to deal with them
and if we want to understand where we
are today if we want to understand the
politics of the Democratic Party for
example and the kinds of constraints
within the Democratic Party sort of what
Obama needs to do moving forward we need
to go back and look at what Bill Clinton
was trying to do in the 1990s as he
tried to move the Democratic Party
toward the center to be very successful
at the presidential level after all Bill
Clinton you know elected in 1992 and
1996 you know the first Democrat to be
to win two elections since Franklin
Roosevelt you know this was you know a
huge huge thing for the democratic party
which had really been seen as a party
that really wasn't even capable of
winning the presidency until Clinton won
in 1992 and so you know understanding on
the Democratic side sort of what the
Clinton years mean without sort of
thinking about him as they were
distorted during the primary campaign
Hillary Clinton was running and then on
the Republican side understanding that
while it seemed that the Republicans
would be unified again after nine eleven
the way they've been during the Cold War
we've seen that evaporate the
Republicans are divided again among you
know the more traditional pragmatic
realists the neoconservatives there's
still some isolationists there you have
some protectionism and anti-immigration
sentiment and part of the Republican
Party and that those divisions have been
there since the end of the Cold War so
understanding that John McCain is
dealing with a party that's been divided
now for almost 20 years and if he wins
he'll face continue to face those
divisions if he loses those divisions
will really explode well you know again
I mean the administration use that
notion try to make the case look
whatever you thought about before you
know the world has changed it's a
totally new thing we know how to deal
with it it's a war on terror and we're
going to we're going to prosecute this
and you know and this is a this is going
to be American foreign policy I mean
part of the you know what we faced in
the last few years we've seen a rise in
America's unpopularity around the world
which you know really needs to be turned
around by the next president certainly
America is facing huge economic problems
in a way that you know it was not at the
end of the 1990s America was very
prosperous at the end of the Clinton
years we have it is a world in which
America is still the leader still the
most powerful country militarily it's
still the leading country economically
it's the leading country politically and
diplomatically you don't solve world
problems without the United States mean
those who tried to forge ahead on Kyoto
to deal with climate change you can't
solve climate change without the United
States in the lead but that leadership
is harder because there are other
entities out there the European Union is
stronger Russia's more assertive China
continues to grow India stronger Brazil
is stronger I mean it is a it is a more
challenging world in that sense than the
1990s but the United States is still the
leading country and can be seen as the
leader needs to restore a lot of respect
for itself and how it behaves and how it
you know I mean issues like torture
which both senator Obama and Senator
McCain you know have articulated
policies different from the Bush
administration in order to try to get a
handle on America's image in the world
which is very important to restore I
think there's a lot of hunger out there
for that restoration of America
you